Transcriptor: Malena GP
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
(Aplausos)
Buenas tardes.
¿A cuántos de ustedes les dijeron en qué
área podían o no desarrollarse?
Y que a pesar de esto, corrieron el riesgo
de intentarlo y les salió bien.
Veo caras a través de la pantalla,
asintiendo igual que esta,
porque a mí me paso.
Sócrates dice: “Conócete a ti mismo”.
Primero debemos conocernos a nosotros
mismos,
saber qué queremos
y qué no queremos.
Y a partir de ahí, luchar por lo que
sí queremos,
porque sabemos que las sociedades
y el entorno intentan influir en nuestras
decisiones y en nuestro pensamiento.
Como estudiante de Ingeniería industrial
me recuerda todo esto que estoy comentando
a mi búsqueda de mi primera pasantía.
Tenía en claro que debía hacerme tres
preguntas,
¿En qué área quiero trabajar?
¿En cuál puedo?
y ¿en cuál no quiero?
Me respondí que sabía
en qué área no quería,
pero no tenía en claro en cuál sí.
Cuando comencé la búsqueda conseguí un
programa donde ofrecían distintas áreas.
Y cuando recibí la primera llamada
me comentaron
que sería en el área de mantenimiento,
un área donde nunca
imaginé que podría trabajar.
Sin embargo, como la rana René,
me llené de miedo e incertidumbre
porque sabía que también esto es
un área que está abocada a los hombres.
Pero aún así acepté el desafío porque
vaya que me encantan los desafíos.
Fui a mi entrevista,
con alegría, con mucha incertidumbre
y para dar lo mejor de mí.
Obtuve la oportunidad.
Y esto me llenó de mucha emoción,
porque sabía que representaba
muchas cosas por aprender.
¿Por qué fui a la entrevista?
Porque para mí, arriesgarme es no quedarme
con la duda de qué hubiese pasado.
De que sé que la vida está llena de
sorpresas y que hacerlo es no quedarme
con la duda de no hacer.
Como dice Gustavo Bueno: “Todos tenemos
miedo de hablar en público”.
Cerrado este ciclo,
comencé a trabajar en esta área con tan
solo 23 años,
con ganas de dar lo mejor de mí.
Y aprender muchas cosas.
Así que conocí personas increíbles.
Cada vez que recuerdo esto me llena
de gran satisfacción,
porque crecí tanto en lo profesional
como en lo personal.
Cuando comencé de nuevo
la búsqueda laboral,
conseguí la oportunidad,
quizás por cuestiones del destino,
de implementar mis conocimientos
en mi experiencia anterior
y ampliarlos en un proyecto
de implementación
dentro de la gestión de repuestos.
Fui a la entrevista,
obtuve el trabajo y lo acepté.
¿Por qué?
Porque soy una persona que le encanta
proponerse metas y luchar por sus sueños
y este proyecto para mí significa
una oportunidad de desarrollarme
y de crecer como persona.
Y todo lo que vienen haciendo las empresas
durante el transcurso de los años
gracias a la lucha que han
venido haciendo las mujeres,
ha sido muy importante y lo sé porque
he conocido mujeres dentro de estas
organizaciones que son maravillosas
y que dan lo mejor de sí cada día,
y sé que a muchas de ustedes
no les sucede lo mismo.
Que todavía hay empresas que no hablan
de esto para seguir con lo tradicional
o lo conocido y así evitarse problemas.
Pero independientemente de las políticas
que coloquen las organizaciones,
debemos arriesgarnos,
dar lo mejor de nosotros,
siendo comprensivos
y  con el poder de la enseñanza.
Porque ¿cuántos de ustedes se hicieron o
hicieron algún comentario y a los minutos
se dieron cuenta de que no estaba bien?
Yo.
¿Por qué?
Porque crecemos con creencias erróneas que
debemos identificar y darnos cuenta
de que no están bien y que
las debemos cambiar.
Debemos abrazar la diversidad.
Porque cada persona, independientemente
de su género, sexo, tiene mucho que
ofrecer al mundo y que en la diversidad
podemos encontrar cosas maravillosas.
Así que los invito a arriesgarse.
Sé que la sociedad y el entorno marcan
una advertencia de lo que podemos
enfrentarnos, pero no debemos dejar que
esto defina nuestro camino.
Para que en algunos años
la conversación no sea cómo llegar,
sino cómo ser mejores líderes.
Y antes de finalizar y agradecerles
por haberme escuchado,
quiero contarles un secreto sobre mí.
Cuando comencé a decorar mi habitación
conseguí un montón de imágenes
con frases que me recuerdan que estoy
hecha y que puedo llegar a ser.
Y una de ellas es esta.
De John Keo:
“Hay un poder infinito dentro de mí“.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)